[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya se está alistando el rosa
pérez masdéu para abrir esta revista de
prensa con una información que está cada
tanto maria antonia sánchez vallejo en
el país españa como meet me en el new
york times' se trata de la muerte de un
joven negro desarmado a manos de un
policía blanco esto en eeuu continúa
entonces esta polémica en ese país para
eso entonces ya está rosa pérez más de o
para hablarnos a los detalles de lo que
acabamos de introducir rosa muy buena
mañana de jueves buenos día raúl
exactamente no como decías así titula
del país dice la policía del estado de
michigan abrió una investigación para
determinar las circunstancias de la
muerte de patrick y ahora es un joven
bueno era ya falleció este joven de de
origen congolés de 26 años que desde el
2014 residía en eeuu y que el pasado 4
de abril murió a manos de un policía
blanco estadounidense cuya identidad no
ha sido revelada e insistimos los hechos
ocurrieron el pasado 4 pero ayer las
autoridades de la municipalidad de grand
rapids en el estado de michigan donde
tuvo lugar este homicidio sacaron a la
luz vídeos que pues muestran lo sucedido
no muestran los hechos desde distintos
puntos de vista desde la cámara del
coche patrulla en la cámara corporal del
propio agente que mató al joven lee hola
como desde la cámara del celular del
copiloto del yola y lo que vemos en las
imágenes es lo siguiente y es que el
yola va conduciendo su automóvil cuando
la policía le pide que se detenga porque
sospecha que la placa que lleva en el
vehículo no corresponde realmente con la
que debería llegar a llevar ese auto no
lee o la sale del coche y entonces
empieza una forcejeo con la policía
entonces vemos como el lío la tiene a
miedo de la situación porque intenta
escapar corriendo no ni siquiera vuelve
a entrar en el vehículo y el policía lo
empieza a perseguir empiezan a forcejear
por el taller del policía hasta que el
policía tumba al joven negro en el suelo
y acto seguido le dispara en el cuello
en la parte
de la cabeza en la nuca exactamente y en
ese momento vemos como él y ahora deja
de moverse el momento exacto de la
ejecución solo se ve en el vídeo captado
por el copiloto del y ahora la cámara
corporal de la gente deja de hecho de
filmar momentos antes del disparo no se
sabe si de forma intencionada o no de
momento el agente está suspendido de su
actividad pero sigue percibiendo su
sueldo de hecho raúl si te parece hemos
seleccionado un extracto de las imágenes
de esta cámara corporal de la gente no
hemos querido seleccionar las imágenes
donde se ve la ejecución pues de forma
muy explícita porque son pues muy
fuertes no pero veamos si te parece un
poco estos segundos de vídeo para que
para mostrarles el contexto no de este
homicidio
bien justo después de estos instantes en
los que acaba esta afirmación es cuando
tiene el lugar puede ser la matanza de
patrick le hola a manos de este policía
blanco
recordemos que yo la iba desarmado tal y
como ha expresado la propia policía de
michigan también insistir en que
distintas organizaciones no señalan los
abusos constantes que recibe la
población afro a manos de la policía
esto mientras la reforma federal que
quería impulsar el vaivén de los cuerpos
policiales está en el aire y bien tanto
el artículo del país como el del 'new
york times' nos dan distintos datos
sobre violencia policial y es que en lo
que llevamos de 2022
250 personas han muerto por disparas por
disparos de policías en acto de servicio
en eeuu éstos según los datos del
'washington post' por otro lado entre
2020 y 2021 mil personas murieron a
manos de la policía y cuando tuvo lugar
el juicio por el asesinato de georges
floyd el 'new york times' éste insiste
que la mayoría de víctimas policiales
eran afro afrodescendientes y latinas y
también por acabar raúl según el 'new
york times' en los últimos cinco años la
policía ha matado a 400 conductores pues
en una detención de tráfico no 400
conductores desarmados